herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
live chat ihrer setting up mal zusammen
mit luca ein video gemacht bisschen
gehört auch unseren beiden familien da
haben wir wer kann besser lügen gespielt
denn das hier zwischen uns ist eine
trennwand stereo mäßig sorten und prüfen
welche verhindern soll dass wir sehen
was der andere vor dem tisch auf sich
hat ist ein schuhkarton vorbereitet mit
fünf gegenständen und fünf weitere
gegenstände werden wir nur erfinden dann
sagen mir hey ich habe von diesen
gegenstand der andere sagt glaube ich
dir oder gleich den psycho spieler kann
ich sagen legen wir los
es gab sogar anfangen dann nehme ich
meine ersten artikel heraus und war das
erste was ich hier habe ein verein noch
verpackte usb stick ok also ich weiss
dürft ihr das nicht wollt gekauften
gebraucht dafür ein usb stick sprechen
ich weiß auch dass du den verkäufer
gesagt hast ja ich hab schon usb stick
und ich glaube kaum dass du den usb
stick hat als hartes und der noch
original verpackt ist es wert sagte sie
vielleicht ist ein usb stick aber erst
nicht verpackt
du musst da hatte ich erhalte ich sage
es keinen verpackten usd genannt
ok dann würde ich sagen schnappe ich mir
mal einen artikel
du schaust beiträgt ich hatte in meiner
hand ein stück klopapier einfach nur ein
glas einsatz über 40 jahren die sache
ist wir wollen unsere sachen raus
besucht haben
marx wieder kindern aufnahme zimmer
gegangen direkt daneben ist eine
toilette
ich glaube allerdings dass du denkst
dass ich für weitere deswegen sage ich
müsste es kein stück klopapier nahm
roman heißt
es gebe noch 0 0 oder 1
ich will eins zu eins das was ich gerade
haltemarken stäbchen für duft behälter
direkt abhilfe leisten
doch überall produkt teile er stimmt
hier direkt auch etwas ist es eigentlich
auch nicht unwahrscheinlich dass du noch
mal extra stäbchen dafür hat aber
andererseits muss man die eigentlich
nicht austauschen
er verbreite ich glaube den michel
d'hooghe öffentlich eher nein muss man
die ausgaben jetzt ist er tot
dann abonnieren er muss man sie auch
laufen die dinge mehrere waren dabei
zwei völker als nächste video auf in
ihrer volksvertretung kann ich mir einen
dollar pro film
ich habe in meiner hand einfach
integration also hab ich gesagt
die nächste sache macht sich hier für
dich vorbereitet habe hierhin auch meine
weitere fragen
die daten liegen haben mag dass ein hack
trieben lauter schlüssel alarm
warum brauchen der garten der hand von
karate kid i schiffbauerdamm inklusive
led terror solltest du so akkurat
beschreiben damit ich denke dass das
fahrzeug vor überfall ich gedacht es
nicht hat staat dadurch hast du hast
eine hand sichern
unterstützen kunden bei veröffentlicht
vom paket können wir nur einmal ran team
übergibt es nicht das ganze leben
möglich gemacht oder einem schlüssel und
dem kanal verdammte spielt unentschieden
nicht doch jetzt schon fragte keine
spielspaß verspricht den club zum 21
deshalb ist meine hand minecraft und
command von materie von vier stunden
gefehlt hat ich glaube ja richtig okay
dann weitergeht ich finde das ist so
schwierig eigentlich ist alles man kann
so ein bisschen hinter der fassade
schauen dass erarbeitet weil formatieren
verständigt weil er fast an das wird so
viele details gerade verraten zu dem
schluss nutzen einfach waren zwölf als
nächstes hiernach habe ich einen multi
detector direktor er wird auch noch
können die dinge nur die detector das
damit zusammen kauft aber wenn man
direkt hier
3 in meiner hand halte ich einen wenn
auch in einer szene oder fiktiv ich weiß
nicht ich ja gerade heraus ob der uns
gefehlt hat
ich glaube ja ja so heißt die sind
gerade nicht auf dem extra angedreht er
ist ja bei karte gehört es dann denken
ja genau der will mich jetzt diesen dann
liegt es wieder rein weiß nicht mehr
warum hast du noch keine die nächste
sache diese vorbereitet habe eine
holland flagge eine kleine verlage
ansatz für das besitzen
warum sie nicht ich sage du hast wie
extra rauszuholen auf die hauptsächlich
noch den leuten gesagt ja keine rolle
anfrage
vielleicht habe ich bin oder ritzen noch
madrid eigentlich so da machen wir mal
weiter hoffen ich habe in meiner hand
ein paar haferflocken wach wird so wie
sie sind auch oder haferflocken bereitet
wird matschig und haferflocken
[Musik]
nein ich weiß nicht welche rausgenommen
deswegen hatte ich extra hingegen die
show aufgefächerten ding mitgenommen
hatte aber die wirklich hätte wenn du so
verlaufen wie viel gelesen aber ich bin
wohl zum start für die strecke ist 3 zu
irgendwie beruhigend über andere
youtuber drehen und horten sagen im
schneiden monate lang für ihre liebes
und tücher film verwerfen schlecht und
packen aber die nächste sache nicht
richtig damit kann ich schon mal
verfügen und zwar ich habe hier ein
kondom du deine fucking kondoliert für
video in jedem video gibt keine
richtigen kondoms hole ich sage nein du
hast jetzt würde ich langsam auf es
jedoch bezweifelt ich habe in meiner
hand packt habt ihr backpapier
packpapier habt ihr mit immerhin
packpapier mit dem man taktgenau unserem
paket mit rein stopps zum beispiel ein
fluggast packpapier dann den flug
aktionär herzlich ich heute sagen dass
du auch bei den katalanen mit länger
überlebt
sieben typen und parken hier drinnen
habe noch verpackte regenmantel regen
wartet also und schon hast was du hast
jetzt wird anzieht kann
hast du ja ja ja ich habe etwa auf dem
boden gelegt ihr kennt mich leider 4000
und -10
ich habe in meiner hand eine reine
rhein-main in recke eigentlich alle drei
strecken durchgeführt das kleine gefährt
wo es keine
ich habe da noch eine sache wenn du auch
noch einer
ich hab nur eine lupe das große finale
steht zweifelsfrei fest du musstest du
banal kann er ja oder nein sagen aber
überlegungen die man an stellt in seinem
kopf macht er das vielleicht um mich zu
verarschen aber dann macht das ja dann
doch um mich nochmal zu verachten für so
komplex eigentlich damals einfach
verschlossen als nächstes habe ich ein
bild von einer person in einer
innenstadt
aber ob das auch wirklich hat der
fotograf ist jürgen müller müller müller
jürgen müller feierte nicht
wie kommst du denn auch jürgen möllemann
gegend wieder rausgeflogen war
heute bietet 10 für mich okay mit meinem
beruf es ist minecraft und command von
kontrakte für auf junge aller zeiten
geht an den gewinner die chance
begreifen
hier findet ihr video main kanal in der
beschreibung
ssg